So in this lesson, I brought together concepts of focal length, field of view,
and sensor size.
I discussed the impact focal length has on how an image is formed.
Both on the creative sides a little bit, but also on the technical side.
As to what you can get in terms of field of view and focal length.
Also discussed perspective projection, which allows you to
kind of start looking at objects that are further away or closer.
And how that is impacted with focal lengths.
Lot of basic material, but
we will continue to advance further and see more details in the next lesson.
For example, we look at exposure triangle.
We, we'll actually look at aperture,
shutter speed and also more information about the sensor size or sensor values.
That has, perhaps gives us more control on what the photography process is
all about.
Of course, we're looking at this because we want to try to understand how
we're going to bring them towards computation.
Again, I've listed a couple of books for you to look at if you're interested.
I do use a lot of resources on the web, please look at, look them up.
More will be available on the website.
And again, thanks to Professor Christensen who provided us with some
amazing images of the Tech Tower and Georgia Tech campus.